yeah the way that I I I think of this
that I that I teach this in our course
is um you know sort of three levels
level one get going level two get good
and level three get smart so get going I
would say is like the first three videos
just like put the videos on there it
doesn't matter like don't overthink it
because loads of people get stuck in
overthinking um especially if they've
come from a background where they've
been to University and done well or
they've or already been in a job and
done well suddenly to go into YouTube
it's like oh the overthinking stops them
from doing from doing anything just make
a handful of videos see how it feels
what the vibe is and then I would say
level two is get good which is still
while you have a day job like get good
at the craft of actually making videos
and get to a point where the stuff
you're making no longer makes you cringe
and as soon as you stop cringing at your
stuff that means it's reached some level
of internal quality but if you start
getting responses from the audience like
like comment subscribes whatever the
thing might be that's an external
barometer for is the thing you're making
actually good and at that point now that
you know how to make a thing that is
good then we can worry about like are we
treating this like a hobby or are we
treating it like a business if it's a
hobby do what you want have fun do your
Ed your own covers no one cares if we're
treating it like a business a business
exists to serve an audience agre and
therefore like all the things around
treating it like a business I I would
say that's the other you know that's the
question before the question about the
audience is like why why do you want to
do it right is it is it a hobby or is it
do you have commercial intent or do you
not know yet you don't have to know when
you start you know like commercializing
your creativity is a very complicated
thing to do it's not clean you know it's
not a clean process what do you mean
creativity is a very at least for me
like coming from you know growing up and
and playing music I think about the
concept of writing songs and how
enjoyable it was to write a song and
think about how like songs would just
come I had a lyric book I would write I
would just kind of enjoy the process of
writing music um if that became a
commercial thing right now I don't know
what my relationship with that would be
if I had to do it right or if someone
pays you to do it and if people start
paying you to do it you all of a sudden
are evaluating your ideas based on a
value system that is quantitative and a
quantitative value system as we all know
on YouTube is a uh it's a very just I
think it's a tricky thing to do with
your creativity think about a creative
video idea you're like I love this idea
you put it out it tanks do you still
love the idea or did something just
happen something just change about what
you feel about the
idea you know like you finish the video
you love it and you put it out and based
on if it's a one out of 10 or a 10 out
of 10 you your emotions towards it might
change dramatically yeah there are
videos that I've put out that I've
thought this is really bad and it does
well I'm like oh you know what it was
good all along and you know I actually
love that video now and I would do
another one so that just immediately
when you have performance-based
creativity it's a completely different
thing than
creativity have you ever worked with a
creative person hired a creative person
who's not motivated by
money you may not attract that type of I
don't think so honestly like like even
hearing you guys talk about creative
stuff that's completely the opposite
World from where I've grown up which is
all about like imagine like imagine
working with someone who doesn't care
about the paycheck they really care
about the final outcome of the work in
the way that they would prefer it to be
oh I have students like on my YouTuber
Academy it's so frustrating heard about
these people yeah when they say why is
my channel not growing and I'm
like like who who's the audience like
what's like why should someone watch you
it's like oh no but I I really wanted to
make this and I I think it's really I
think my message is really important
yeah okay but like clearly other people
don't so like I think mistake the
sometimes creatives mistake what's
happening on YouTube for creativity uh
and and that there isn't a lot of
creativity on YouTube yeah not that
there isn't but again like let's let's
take a look at the film industry yeah
why are there so many
Spider-Mans because it's commercially
successful it works because it puts
butts in
seats okay that's just like the simplest
thing I can say about the film business
right so if you want to be in the film
business if you were to decide I want to
be in the film business you're playing
by those rules what puts butts and seats
if you want to be a filmmaker you can be
a filmmaker but you might not play with
the film business it might intersect a
couple of times but those are it's okay
for those to decoupled yeah right it's
like how it's like how someone who
enjoys making coffee is very different
to someone who runs a profitable coffee
business or coffee shop completely
different completely different things
with like minor overlap but like broadly
complet different things yeah different
things um col Colin said this to me one
time he was like I think uh we we
thought YouTube was about monetizing
self-expression but it's
not does that make sense it can be of
course within certain confines and in
many ways you look at our Channel what
we're doing right now your channel sure
you are monetizing a bit of
self-expression but there are
compromises which gets increasingly more
difficult when you're compromising on
yourself yeah yeah you know and and all
this to say we found a format that for
me at least I feel has allowed for me to
be myself and an uncompromised version
of myself and that intersect with
commercial viability and I feel really
lucky about that because there was a lot
of versions of like attempts at YouTube
that I was not I was not being 100%
myself you know and I I if I was good at
not being myself I would have pursued
acting which I wanted to do but I wasn't
good at it I can't pretend for that long
um and so I'm I feel very grateful that
we found a format where it's like when
you watch our videos like I that is me I
am Samir in that context I'm not playing
a role like we had coffee with James
Hoffman before this um at his coffee
shop and we spent three hours with him
basically funny enough felt like we did
a podcast without recording it it's like
it's exactly the conversations we enjoy
having it's exactly the people I'm
interested in it's exactly how I show up
in those conversations and I feel really
lucky that that is what we get to to do
but for the record I'm a paid
actor make sure that that's clear for
everyone listening watching I do have to
ask myself how many of these
conversations would I do if if it wasn't
tied to you know Commercial Success how
much would I upload how much you right
like you you do have to think about that
too it's like okay is this what you know
and that's what running a creative
business is you know and I think that's
that's the thing the advice I would give
is like just get really smart on
understanding what making it means to
you like what is making it to you what
is what does that mean to like make it
on YouTube what do you imagining in your
head and then also like you know do you
deeply authentically care about
providing value to the audience that
you've told me you you want to have
because if you do then you can have a
long career um then you're going to wake
up every day and be like okay this
lifestyle is really enjoyable the
process of making videos is really
enjoyable I get to do the thing I'm
passionate about I feel like myself
while I'm doing it and the people on the
other side are really happy and I I get
joy from providing value to
them hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye-bye